hey guys this is Reuben report now with
mugs i'm dave rubin and i have two of my
favorite people i often say favor people
but we have two great people you know
sometimes I say greater favorite and
then it's like one good person and one
kind of throw away this week not the
case miss Kelly Carlin Chad I'm binder
welcome to the big show guys very
excited to be here a couch a couch how
do you feel on the couch i thought i'm
asking you relax right now Chad you feel
a little bit of ikea heaven happening is
it okay with it we spared no expense all
right we got a lot to get to so let's
get right to it all right I'm sure you
guys have heard about this but there was
an awful plane crash in the French Alps
the plane sent out a distress signal at
10 45 and local time then crash in the
mountainous zone and an altitude of
about 2,000 meters according to the
Germanwings CEO it took the plane eight
minutes to descend before they lost
contact with the plane officials said
there were some clouds but the cloud
ceiling was not low and there did not
appear to be turbulence in a televised
statement German Chancellor Angela
Merkel added this is a time an hour of
great sorrow and great grief we should
be thinking about people who have lost
relatives and also friends all right so
the story is still breaking but it does
sound like all 150 people on board did
die is it just me or we are there more
of these happening now or is this just
the media or are we just aware of
everything more or what but I feel like
playing like every six months I feel
like we're getting one yeah it does feel
like as a major crash more often but I
think there's probably more planes in
the air I mean statistically it's still
very very safe that's what everyone says
right like that's the thing like they
say in your car going to the market yeah
I mean you know which seems weird
because your up 30 38,000 feet or
whatever but yeah but I think it's just
that there I and these planes are
getting older I mean that's part of it
too they said this one's over what was
it like 18 20 years old and they think
oh that's young in this in this field
I'm like really yeah that doesn't know
yeah okay with that yeah dc9 still in
the air uh entity flew on a dc9 yeah
yeah I don't know but it's it always uh
not the MTV Veejay Kennedy yeah the
press you men John John F Kennedy
I'm our younger viewers yeah well
Kennedy where's about empty the MTV
Kenny work for fox now so she's by you
know flying in something laughing
applause I understand it right uh really
do you think these things are happening
more does it feel like it's happening or
do you think is a function of the media
it's a function of the media you know i
mean the the classic line was from the
original superman movie with Christopher
Reeve or he turns to somebody and I
think he turns to Lois Lane and says you
know statistically speaking flying is
still safer than any type of travel yeah
but that's like saying well people who
shave get cut and those of you that
don't know okay so if somebody says that
every 15 minutes ray it's the repairing
do that guys think it's a control thing
cuz I've talked about a lot I don't like
to fly really at four years I was
drugging myself on flights I don't do it
anymore but now I just freaked out for
half the flight but you think it's a
control thing like when you get in your
car even if it's statistically a higher
chance of getting hit by on the way to
sue market that you're at least
controlling a portion of it versus the
plane yes you're in a metal tube hurling
your body through space yeah tens of
thousands of feet above the earth we're
not talking about the car yeah yeah it
does not help in my case there's nothing
in that that makes a person who likes to
have a little bit of control in their
life comfortable right at all and all I
and all I ever think about is well at
least the pilot is probably got decades
of experience he's flown this playing a
lot and then of course you know they
lead yesterday with the story how the
pilot had decades of experience yeah I
don't even have that to calm me down
anymore in an airplane right oh we are
completely screwed yeah and I to your
first point I I always still drugged
myself on an airplane and by the way
also in the car highly recommend you
know I've like a cyclic no see you know
codeine right there I the visor oh don't
like to drug myself in the airplane
because I worry about if we do go down I
don't know I kind of I don't want to be
drugged for like the last two minutes of
my life I've thought of that and I think
if you're going down how what's the
effect of a valium gonna do on yeah I
mean really yeah clearly well the last
time that I measurable I yeah
right you want it to be as stressful as
possible that it's all and like stupid
Buddhist mindfulness thing is like I
want to be present during my dad thing I
don't know yeah that one enjoy the air
slide that's an idiot um well I I would
yeah I would be remiss if we did a story
on planes and didn't just talk a little
bit about the media coverage it's yes
it's pretty horrible and yes we all know
that because of the news cycle every
little thing that happens they they
stretch it out and they bring in they
say we're not going to speculate and
then everything's but it's worth it
somehow seems worse with place doesn't
it and it's I just have to point out CNN
in particular because they're really
addicted to graphics yeah so they have
all these fancy graphics and I've got
enough of an imagination to picture what
it must have been like for the plane to
be going descending down now they've got
these special 3d graphics that are
showing you exactly what's happening so
for your first person shooters at home
yeah way along with the girl terror is
rising up in me and all I could think
yesterday was this is officially plane
crash porn yeah I mean there's no other
way to put it and he'd be disgusting
it's it's horrific and I wanted I had to
turn my TV is the case of cereal because
the case of Siena even particularly more
bizarre because they did the months and
months on the other plane crash and the
plane was never found in yet every day
they were saying breaking news as if
right the breaking news is we found out
i think it was their news director had a
very large hard on yesterday yeah oh yes
everywhere he went the worst part for me
was i watched again this morning now
that there are facts that you know it's
a debris field not the plane pulverized
into a mountain nothing bigger
quote-unquote than the size of a small
car which i thought was going to be some
branded content but they didn't version
of brand of it yeah and then the worst
part of this whole thing is that the guy
explaining the coordination of the
spanish investigation team the german
investigation team and the French mystic
is a French guy nothing worse than
having to be taken through a news cycle
from a guy that sounds like he's too
busy to be here it's a plan it crashed
I'm busy I mean it's horrible i'm
watching this guy he couldn't look more
bored both put off i'm waiting for my
food they must love you
Paris wow I've dated the French they're
not easy anyway what do you think of
this segment do you like to fly let us
know in the comments down below please
Ted Cruz is running for president of
what I have no idea Cruz was first
elected at the US senator three years
ago as a tea party candidate defeating
Texas attendant governor david Dewhurst
all right so Ted Cruz basically strikes
me as a used car salesman with a little
extra pinch of Jesus or something in
there how do you guys feel about I know
you're big right-wingers big tea party
people both of you how do you feel about
the Ted well I went to the wiki page for
Ted Cruz and it's actually Cuban for
asshat what Tigers actually translate
though I mean this guy it's you know
it's it's one of those scary things it's
that whole dead zone you know the Martin
Sheen character you know these guys are
so ridiculous but that makes them also
so incredibly dangerous it's sarah palin
with a penis you know sooner way more
educated a smart so that's the dangerous
party is intelligent he's a good speaker
he's very ambitious yeah he uh I was
reading about him last night more in
depth of what he stands for and there's
some things like he wants to go after
Wall Street yeah let's go after Wall
Street I mean that you know there's some
of that tea party stuff that I that I
agree with but this does make him very
dangerous now but the thing is that he
is so right wing and he loves pissing
off the mainstream Republicans and we
know that even if he does well in Iowa
even if he does well in you know in New
England the mainstream party boss guys
are not going to let this guy get away
with anything he's not Reagan right so
address so basically he'll do well in
those early primaries when you have to
really go to the base and the tea party
about to Iowa let's not forget michelle
bachman one yet first tea party yes or
the first iowa straw poll yeah well my
view is so much more radical on all
these guys you know we bring up Reagan
it's like you know the rake you know
Reagan was one of the biggest criminals
ever completely you know he's treated he
cut the Human Services budget which
created the homeless population which we
now just feed people into because
there's no beds because they took
well the federal funding the guy was a
complete criminal and to like hold him
up now is like well that's the far right
barrier that we don't want to cross over
and guys like crews are so dangerous and
so incredibly wrong and lie on just
about every sentence the guy says about
Obama I thought about protecting Obama
and his legacy and and uh uh standing as
a president it's that this guy's lips
are moving he's lying yeah and nobody
calls them on a week we all fall into
this like well you know who was it I
other day of Reagan yeah you think
partly if that nobody knows what's true
anymore like it's so hard to to siphon
through truth in this crazy media world
that like they say saying you know like
Ted Cruz will be like Obamacare is
bankrupting the country we lost three
hundred million dollars by the time I
started that sentence and then you and
then no of course but then you know
you'll turn on MSNBC and they'll say
it's the greatest thing ever end and
that somewhere between that my guess is
what the truth is but you just don't
know what we are lazy uninformed
citizens and you have to do a lot of
research to get the truth and people
will feed you whatever their biases in
the media you know and it's easier it's
like okay you're confirming my bias
already now I don't need to think yeah
but breaking news and this is from this
morning he signed up for Obama now I
love it he signed up for obamacare well
he had to know he did because i'll take
my grill down yeah he could go straight
to any insurance company and sign up I
or Cobra he could have done Cobra you
know you can't afford it cuz like ninety
percent of all of us great Americans a
cheap asthma yeah right now he's always
gonna get those federal subsidies like
I'll take them yeah so just to be to be
absolutely think the guy is literally
running on his number one thing the
money that getting rid of Obama
government because of Obamacare yeah
that he's now signed up that he signed
up for this morning so what are we
supposed to make these guys like Ted
Cruz who their whole thing is reversing
things so he wants to reverse Obama care
whether you like Obamacare not that the
country didn't start exploding like it
wrote that he wants to reverse gay
marriage like this is totally I get he's
not a progressive that sorry once they
want to dismantle every by the way he's
in charge of one of the foundations that
runs NASA this is a guy who doesn't even
believe in climate change yeah we're
science yeah so what are we doing yeah
this is what I'd really be like in a
large big picture cultural ways
these guys come up and and the you know
our system works on the fact that the
far right and the far left stretch at
each other and that we all come together
somewhere in the middle and compromise
that is what that is the political
system we live in yeah he's doing his
job as a guy the ones used to live in
yes that's true ideally right the right
just kept pulling so far kept dragging
ever exactly as so he's doing his job as
the one who wants to dismantle
everything and of course you know if we
can turn back the clock to the 1900s
when there was none of these regulatory
place you know agencies and things yeah
look at you know child labor and I mean
just everything was horrific so it's an
insane thought but for me ah I am happy
about it because I think people like
this motivate the other side's base no
it motivates them to get busy to vote to
get the truth out about these kind of
you know candidates and and get people
off their asses and and you know yeah I
basically agree with that that the guys
that are on the fringe of both sides it
usually seems to be on the right that
they do actually empower a lot or
activate a lot of the people on the left
to like wake up be like oh yeah we
decrease a very lazy day GI you agree
that no I can't and I'll tell you why
because that's one of those like well
you know that's going to help me get up
off my couch and stop playing video
games to go vote what if let's just play
this game for a second what if a sarah
palin gets you know one heartbeat and a
couple of menstrual cycles away from the
presidency network has a dramatic one of
a crazy mix an asshat like Ted Korea
becomes the vice president yeah and then
you know somebody so for whatever
reasons he ends up being the present you
know then we were like oh I guess we
weren't motivated now these guys are so
dangerous no I agree because Saudi when
Bush was running the first time I
thought it's a way yeah well we all know
he kind of illegally got the president
wrote a presidency but but it happened
and Lord we are now because of it yeah
lovely all right so and yes of course I
remember that we you have to be you have
to be stride with these people as trying
as they are and it is it is terrifying
and yet the comedians are all licking
their lips are very happy absolutely the
comedians are all right well what
you think are we being too tough on Ted
Cruz is Ted Cruz the Antichrist let us
know in the comments right down below
alright so we had to do one story on
Isis that I saw this morning uh Tatooine
which you probably know from Star Wars
that's where Luke and his family lived
was the desert planet Tatooine uh was
shot and filmed in back in the 70s in
Tunisia in a city in a town called
Tatooine chatham i write on all the job
are so far out of this uh and it has
just fallen the actual town it's spelled
slightly differently than the way they
did in Star Wars but the actual town of
tattooing has fallen to Isis um you know
we did a story couple weeks ago about
Isis destroying all these artifacts in
Iraq and to create these things the
ancient artifacts that have existed for
you know hundreds and thousands of years
um and when I saw story with it's
incredibly upsetting but this one I mean
Star Wars I've got it in the set right
there I love Star Wars almost everything
i believe is based in Star Wars the book
like this one hit me in a different way
I was like I mean this this [ __ ] is just
completely out of control I know that
sounds crazy because they're beheading
people in burning people and I don't
want to dismiss any of that but when you
can actually destroy future artifacts
that that's a strange thing whoo that's
good that's powerful right right I get
what we call a thinker whoa that was
right because that's some peers from now
people like right MP they were just
months ago they literally they had tours
to go there people would go on vacation
you see where Star Wars was shot and
it's literally being overtaken by I do
you think this will actually motivate
the American public to get behind real
military action now because they're Star
Wars satisfied you know I know you're
being slightly sarcastic but I was a
little more for military action after at
least fire of my death star you had the
virus today a recruitment office near my
house that you know and clearly these
are the droids they're looking for yeah
but but there is something serious here
because it is there's a fondness yeah we
all have a personal fondness to this
mythology in the story and this memories
from our child of seeing this these
films and so it does hit us in a very
interesting real way right so that these
other things are
our way and horrible but don't actually
hit us personally but I depart I
completely agree if it's right in the
Star Wars culture of you know what what
better metaphor for the dark side of the
force Wow yeah then Isis man you know
yeah that even even the Arab nations are
starting to oh yeah is it Saudi Arabia
is now lining up their troops at the
border make yeah now going to start no
idea is attacking them Jordans attacking
them so in the network so isn't that the
interesting part of this that fine is
that it is that the good part of
everything that's happening with Isis
that maybe they number the rest of the
world i think is so yeah like they've
like Star Wars is gonna push everybody
rich by other nations are finally being
like this shit's going on in our
backyard and that maybe America doesn't
have to do every you go is very few your
ass away from my Tatooine that's what is
coming down to I'm just make sure you
bring us home you kids out there you
like to do fun videos someone dress up
in cosplay and do a cosplay versus Isis
oh that's a somebody's gonna happen one
of you listeners Watchers out there ya
like like Raphael from ninja turtles
versus that it sounds like all EG how
about c-3po trying to negotiate with one
of these jihadi John or whatever these
dads Kenobi when we need in where is he
when you need him anyway what do you
guys think it's a terrible story did the
idea that this town is being ransacked
glasses no no it's it's really upsetting
to me what do you think could star wars
start getting people to gin up maybe do
saying should we do anything let us know
in the comments right down below soon
Snoop won't be the only stone dog a
senator Nevada is proposing a new
provision to a bill that would give
veterinarians the right to prescribe
medical marijuana to dogs the senator is
hoping to add the provision to a new
bill known as SB 372 that will overhaul
Nevada's medical marijuana law I want to
move to Nevada just so that I can say my
senator is named tick segerblom I like
this tick segerblom like him to stone
dogs I know you guys you're both dog
people you're both you know you're for
medicals yeah and you look terrible
glaucoma
of the marijuana how many dogs are our
gotten stoned economy let's can't even
count could anyone possibly be against
this know how but I'm sure that we'll
find them yeah I'm sure they'll come out
we have out of the woodwork yeah I I
just think I like the cat people right I
just that it's the pro cat now a lot of
people are gonna be against yeah grumpy
cat that cat could use a little grumpy
cat angela louise yeah yeah so I I don't
get it well under no circumstances the
whole entire Jack Russell Terrier line
should be stuck all the time no offense
well yes that will that's where we can
be done here that's nice did a bunch of
dogs and what kind of weed daily life
and sativa indica anyway uh so I at some
level I can understand I am obviously
totally for legalizing weed altogether
and certainly for medicinal marijuana
for children for anyone that needs it
for any kind of medicinal yeah purpose
but I guess I could understand that some
level somebody that would say they're
against weed recreationally cuz it's
gonna screw with your mind I don't
believe any of that it's never proven
now no one commits crime on pot blah
blah blah but what I don't get is how
could anyone be against this for animals
right your dogs not going to get stoned
and go do that bad stuff that they think
people are gonna do no but really who
needs a dog who's got the munchies yeah
really they're already begging yeah your
dog Stella is a big jumper already
begging yeah now I've got a begging dog
who's also got the munchies this
concerns me a little bit that's my only
fear yeah all right munchies that's an
issue exact was the doggy treats not for
the people that own Purina let's go
there yeah and the other issue about
this is this is once again you know this
crazy insane idea we have about hemp and
you know marijuana are the cannabis is
you know that you know Empress been
outlawed in this country because it's
related to the cannabis plant I mean and
hemp if you read the you know people who
use Hampton want to use it for all sorts
of things it could like change change
the world anyway can you so we've talked
about this a little bit of trouble can
you just explain a couple of things that
hemp could be used for bi there's hemp
milk of course which is legal
like direction of greater level of hemp
is like you know way higher than like
chicken and beef and which is you know
killing the planet with right takes much
less energy to produce honor I don't you
know creates gas and all that oil
rotation it's not as hard on the soil as
a crop rotation fiber I mean it's just
it's a I I'm not a hemp freak yet but I
read this stuff and I think this is lets
you know if you want to do logic let's
do logic and this is what drives me
crazy about this stuff there's no
science there's no logic they just
ignore it and they're there you know
marijuana is still deemed as dangerous
as heroin you know as far as it's a
class a class A drug yes and which by
the way a class A drug the definition
because it says in it in the definition
it says that there's no medicinal value
right right which then at the same time
we have states that are doing medicinal
marijuana so our laws make no sense yes
it's all political and that's what
you're you know it's like let's in
science I just want to see science over
and over again I am well and and just
being practical I mean but let's look at
the positive of this for a second if you
own a dog if you're out there America
yeah I'm super and you own a dog
immediately go and get that dog a
marijuana license because the next time
you get pulled over you are a medicinal
caregiver and that we that's the dog
yeah and as an administrator the dog
likes it when a what they call thing
you'd take the joint in reverse and
blown into someone's mouth Chaka Chaka
yeah I'm here as the shotgun delivery
suspect that sir for truffles for
truffles yeah right like I'm taking bong
hits to blow into the dog because I'm a
caregiver you're being of service yeah
and watch topic dogs like what other
animals can't we get legalized medical
marijuana Joan giraffes that would be
pretty old fish let's just go across the
board your goldfish have memory problems
as if anywho what do you think stone
dogs of course it should be completely
fine medical marijuana for dogs why
would you not want to help an animal
with a substance that grows from the
earth or that won't stop barking or that
wants that marking let us know what you
think in the comments write down bro
great news for rich white people not
great news for everyone else he
institute said in a youtube video though
the united states is one of the
wealthiest countries too many Americans
this prosperity remains out of reach
blacks and Hispanics who are striving to
make a better life for themselves and
their families are not given the same
asset building opportunities as the
video notes a white person in their 30s
in 1983 had an average net worth of one
hundred and eighty-four thousand dollars
today these whites who are in the early
60s have accumulated 1.1 million dollars
in wealth blacks however only saw their
wealth go from 54,000 to 161,000
Hispanic weld has only grown from 46,000
to 226,000 alright well you can't argue
with the numbers i'm here with white
people the worst kind of people white
people look at the way your wealth you
freaking white people uh well
technically I'm a pink person king of
the thing people yeah so that's between
y'all yeah but I hate white people I'm
very white yeah hottish Irish I'm like
of the worst it's white white so if you
look at those numbers I mean it really
is kind of staggering like something
like but for white people that value
increased something like six fold for
black people it was a little more than
two I think Hispanics not great also so
you know everyone say we're post-racial
it seems like we've had a major slide
back into racial stuff in the last two
years where where are we with the racial
thing and economics in America depressed
yeah it's just it's depressing I saw
that and I was just depressed and I
thought I'm a white person and I don't
know what the hell to do about it i
don't iike I it is just going to get
worse they would ask mantle or social
security every little safety net in this
culture so at any any support that these
communities have they want to wipe out
they they're not interested in helping
you know the republicans and the power
elite are not interested in in creating
and you know a society and economy where
everyone really gets to prosper right so
i think the republicans would argue they
want every would have this even playing
field and if there was an even playing
field as there should be I don't know
what that means really but that's a
little taste but then
but when you look right so does this
really what you're seeing here really is
just how systemic racist or racism or
racial my latest stuff is in the system
that it's just in this it's ingrained
look I mean wisco the Supreme Court
yesterday handed out a decision they
would not hear the Wisconsin voter
totally racist bias Wisconsin voter ID
law so it stands so now if you don't
have a state government issued driver's
license or form of state issued
government ID you can't vote in
Wisconsin right and you know math still
is math I mean it was math when I woke
up this morning so how does it affect
who does it affect if it affects people
of color like a 10 to 1 because it's an
extra expense and if I lose my license
like I don't want to go and pent spent
26 bucks that I would spend on food to
get another license and they just make
it harder for people of color to vote
and the thing is also you know this is
also about obviously this is a racial
issue here but we're also talking about
just the general working poor right
there there's no way out of this stuff
right the general disparities which is
the doctors what one level asset
building in this country look at the
last presidential elections go back to
mathur one second obama won by two
hundred and and you know they'll be
comments about this 226,000 votes they
estimate that nine percent of wisc
wisconsin ians wisconsin or whatever
they are she's hit nine percent which is
about 350,000 don't have this ID right
there it is Obama doesn't win Wisconsin
right so everything is motivated
chipping away they say one thing about a
level playing field and then they do
everything they can to just never do
anything like that and hurt people of
color which is why I hate white people I
mean I absolutely not stand white people
so 300,000 people don't vote obaku do
that state-by-state there's seven other
states that have this now that's how
they will gerrymandering and that is how
they will take the white house's how
they'll keep the Senate so when we
talked earlier in the earlier segment
about well you know the right we just
have to kind of get motivate off them I
said they're so dangerous this kind of
stuff if you're not motivated before the
election is why we don't win the
midterms you're going to watch
everything that you to your great point
all the social services that are barely
there now are gonna go away because
they're rigging the game
yep so less all right it's right there
no is there anything that Obama can do
because I think if you would have asked
the average person I voted for him twice
if you were to basket person will race
relations and some of this systemic
stuff and I'm sup would be better by the
time he leaves he's only got about 20 to
some odd months left it doesn't look
like things are going to be better
either economically or just in terms of
racial tension by the time he leaves is
there anything he can do no because the
owners of this country own everything
and they've got the power whether it's
you know it's Wall Street isn't one of
the owners now I mean I know we're
talking about some high level stuff that
your dad of course he is of course he is
i mean you know i mean i look at my my
i'm not a person makes a ton of money
but I'm way up in that 10 percentile
fifteen percent i don't know it's insane
to think about that but the people who
really own all of the power and have all
the cash in this country uh they're not
interested in changing the system and
there's a few of them that are and bless
them for that but they've got all the
power you know the money is the power
right now and it's been going this way
for the last 30 years since since reagan
I mean especially when the neo-cons
really started plotting all of this 30
years ago they've done a great job and
it was a great country and I really
don't know if it ever will yeah I'm for
roadside sterilization of white people
and I think if you're if you're a person
at any any racial hue bhi roadside
roadside you know I could be like you
know your oil change and snip snip so
Anna burger and if you're of any racial
to start having more babies because the
only way you're gonna change this is to
have such an electorate of color but
that is coming so here in California we
will be the roadside service Asians yeah
all right I have a feeling the
commenters are gonna have a field day
with Chad by the way his twitter is at
Chad underscore I'm binder I think I got
that right and what a whole segment
reminds me of is the great quote from
Kelly's father the legendary George
Carlin which is they call it the
American dream because you have to be
asleep to believe it robotic cars are
coming but will they be able to make
three-point turns we'll find out Elon
Musk
during a conference call that a
hands-free electric car is hitting the
market in just six months the coolest
part of Musk's call may have been when
he announced that if you're on private
property drivers will actually be able
to remotely some in their vehicle and
when they arrived home after dr Tesla
owners will also be able to send their
car back to the garage without actually
having to manually park them all right
so you guys know I love this kind of
story right I love all this futuristic
stuff I love all the robotic stuff i
love wondering when they're gonna come
and destroy us uh what well we didn't
show in the package there is that a lot
must also said that eventually humans
driving could become illegal because we
would then be more dangerous because you
have humans driving with his robot then
he walked that back a little bit because
obviously he has taken Tesla so people
started freaking out about that I've
been in one Tesla once it was after a
party at your house and it wasn't your
test with oh yeah not doing that well I
do it okay but not a lot of envy about
things behave envy about about the Tesla
it was it was all cool futuristic
operation I I was in a Tesla want it at
the pop-up store century city mall yeah
it is the greatest car I've ever just
yeah like I didn't go anywhere I didn't
take the little tester I just sat in the
car yeah and they were like can you come
out of the car now I drove an inmate and
it's pretty for a mean everything's
digital school so that ended in and of
itself it's not a robotic car but these
things are coming yes um so should i
start with the fear question or just the
cool okay take it either all i have to
tell you yesterday no lie i was in
beverly hills driving in one of those
one-way streets and a woman came at me
in her Jaguar and i thought you know if
her car was a robot it would have known
better she clearly does so you're pro a
robot hey pro robot car at this point
cheb the robot car well i would say next
to Ted Cruz running for president this
is the dumbest idea in the history of
dumb ideas okay everybody below this
help traffic it's gonna be like minority
report and we'll be able to burn up all
the cars now where do we all live
California 3 busiest freeways in the
modern free world the four or five the
101 in the tent in the next list
followed by some [ __ ]
freeway in Venezuela would you play
chess in the traffic jams the call just
ordained right it is an Israel I things
another bad one yeah sometimes i'm on
the 405 quick story dead stop i'm in the
center lane cars everywhere i look front
cars right side behind and I go no one's
moving we're all just sitting there and
I go oh my god I'm in the matrix like I
checked I check my shrinker to see
there's one of those but blood sucking
the life out of me driving in this town
within a robot car or car driven by uber
lyft or sidecar it's still a nightmare
it doesn't matter this plane crash was
awake all wire with with a plan they
they move everything digitally so
there's no wire connecting to the
aileron in the weather the flaps so now
we've got a robot car and if there's a
software glitch or its unhackable ya
like like the IRS and everything's on a
keable right a horrible idea right going
to change our lives at all so you're
going directly to the to the negative
side of stuff which is on the future
stuff where I always end up hearing one
way or another but there could be some
short-term positivity here that if
robots were driving cars and you took
that human error out right it might help
traffic it might be good for a while
before the robots turn on us you know
I'm tired of waking up and not having
any hope and this just gives me when I
was a little kid I saw the movie sleeper
yeah and you know Diane Keaton in Woody
Allen down that little cool car and it
drove them somewhere I wanted one of
those damn it i want my waited until
until it broke down and they found a VW
Bug 67 crank top in the cake and it
started right up okay yeah one regular
gas wait how did they have sex in
sleeper I can't really they did some
gears yeah John yeah that's really but
really those window when you invent
those no get an orgasm at Ron that's
what okay that's where this all ends up
right like this all ends with it we're
just in a pie throwing suffocation of us
and we're just gonna end up in a pot and
we're partners is doing that no my
husband this morning was saying that he
also was Elon wants to make this tube
sister yeah you know from huge hyper
hyper hyper loop right right and and my
husband bob was saying that he just
doesn't want to feel like a hamster and
a habit rails
I live for that robotic cars great idea
gonna clean up traffic or are they
coming to kill us let us know your
thoughts in the comments write down
we're getting one step closer to the
pre-crime in Minority Report where is
Tom Cruise when you need them mobile
warrants will give police the ability to
enter a private residence anywhere at
any time but does making a ward
acquisition easier for policeman justice
will be better served in Butte County
police no longer need to physically get
a judge's signature to execute a search
word they can do it all on their iPhone
alright so this story combines a lot of
my favorite stuff the debate that we're
always having about privacy technology
the future on its face this seems scary
to me the idea I get it we're all
walking around with phones so if a cop
wants to get in someone's house instead
of having to go to the judge and go
through the process they can just do it
on their phone and that's the way
technology is going so okay on the on
the other side of it is maybe having
that moment to go to the cop having that
time that allows our system to have some
correction in it and that we shouldn't
just be allowing our law enforcement to
just be willy-nilly like literally
clicking a button having a judge or a
robot somewhere click another button to
say okay you have the warrant go for it
so I there's something about this that I
don't like knowing the trends that we
have in general about privacy and things
ya know I think it's I think it's an
interesting thought but I think the cops
who want these warrants are going to get
them either way right you still have to
go to a judge thankfully and I don't
think but you can do it all on your
phone you don't actually after like file
a paper don't where you can be on the
fly doing this you don't like how we
order pizzas yes correct um you know and
if you know if they're if they're
hunting down a serious criminal and
there's some sort of timing issue I
think this is a great thing you know I
mean you know someone like Robert Durst
ready but uh you know giving police more
power to do their job in ways that harm
people's civil liberties that does scare
me uh okay so we she got there I didn't
know she was gonna come again yeah I see
this as a is it makes no difference you
know the internets faster the world is
faster everything's worse because it's
bastard we talked about that last time
we were on yes so
oh really you know just as a test what I
did was I called in to this location
you're right that is a mobile meth lab I
wanted to test not yet but you know
really what are we doing um I was a
great are you know when you do this show
uh the producers of the show send you
links to the articles in the topics and
I was reading on the right website the
great article about this and they talked
about some of the specifics we're all
they're able to do with this is cut down
the lag time for where a matlab can then
flush the drugs right that guy that i
think is important exact right so I
really what's change though so they get
the warrant faster so they're coming in
to get you and you're completely
innocent of everything in its the you
have the same name as a criminal your
name just happened to be you know Jose
whatever Colombian drug drug dude right
unfortunately for you and you were
raised Jewish which makes no sense that
it just means that that mistake is just
gonna happen faster it's not going to
change the outcome of that you'll be
exonerated right so I get that part
that's what you say us but I do have
this I always have the the concept of
the slippery slope yes suddenly they
that we have issues with law enforcement
and trust of law enforcement right now
and that we're just giving them more
power to quickly do things and how do we
unravel that if it gets out of control
yeah but but the reality is is that
right and but you know this is just one
more thing we're gonna have to keep an
eye on yeah like we don't have enough to
do away yeah how many eyes do we have
now because I'm running out of energy I
like to accurately think in a 360 yeah
does anyone behind me right now get some
of these cameras or there's nobody
behind you there might be anyway digital
search warrants I guess there's
something good there but it seems like a
slippery slope what do you think let us
know in the comments right down below
just do it differently for girls the
sports apparel giant teamed up with the
Japanese fashion label sekai for an
eight-piece nike lab sekai capsule
collection writer megan Wiggins said in
a piece for Slade nike called it a bold
expression of femininity in reality it's
comical and insulting to female athletes
everywhere okay so we're going to link
to the article with this down below and
you'll be able to see some more pictures
if you want when I first saw the article
and I saw what you're seeing there in
the video I thought it was a joke like I
actually thought it was a joke I know
many guys that are athletes I know
many girls that are athletes I get it
girl things have to be cut slightly
differently for their bodies alia made
the hips are a little different you know
the shoes baby could be a little I'm a
gas you don't like it when you're
driving the lane play basketball you
don't like a nice cape ok boat slama
jama you know Kate flutter you know it's
funny that my first my first thought was
picturing myself like jumping in the
cape swoop but really like this seems so
ridiculous because athletics are like
the great equalizer and it's up to you
and you know your abilities and now
girls have to be girlier I know it's so
confusing I thought it was I'm like okay
it's an art piece it's like Yoko Ono it
started designing is something
interesting like that right in a museum
like oh this is some sort of weird idea
of this okay oh they're serious they
really want me to wear a skirt in a cape
while I'm yeah like the Wardrobe the
Wardrobe art direction from a bad 1980's
movie oh yeah Anakin seven it is I'm
horrible what are they smoking there so
is this just all week so I guess the
other part maybe is that this is just
like fashion week when they just like no
like Haute Couture right mañana tea yeah
and no one's gonna wear any of this
stuff that I gotta say I was all about
it at this one you know I can you cut
the whopper scented perfume for the
Phenom story of the nike women's wear I
mean which also justify whatever we were
gonna do a story about whopper scented
perfume but we think it might be an
oncoming April Fool's joke we'll find
out soon enough did you on aa crush
that's not we thought we thought it was
real but they got my big women escape
and did played hoops by myself now i
just i think is one of those this is one
of those things where you know Serena
it's a double standard to Serena
Williams who likes to design is it
Serena or Venus that does the I think
it's area yeah she said designs but if
she would have done something like this
to be a part of couture fashion week
right it would have been Harold as this
great thing but because it's kind of
goofy looking and like bad a tease you
know version of the future movie that
would happen in 2017 you know we're all
up and you know women are being down
trotted and you know look I I I was
raised by women I have women children I
been married to a woman you know I'm Pro
you've got all of the stuff inside
already 60 I got a lot of women around
me all that one right here I'm totally
pro women but this is like we're gonna
get riled over some eight pieces of
clothing yeah yeah denigrating women
little exactly yeah yeah it's one of
those outrage that's like let's distract
ourselves for 30 seconds um but yeah
really if nikes serious about this day I
don't it I mean what's it like for me it
isn't April for maybe this is the baby
this is the April Fool what's the line
from the incredibles movie where the
little Edna moles like okay okay all
right we exercised our outrage on this
one are you upset at Nike let us know in
the comments right now below two buck
chuck at trader joe's is going to kill
you inexpensive wine brands could
contain up to five times more arsenic a
known carcinogen then the amount the
Environmental Protection Agency permits
in drinking water one expert noted the
lower the price of wine on a perlier
basis the higher the amount of arsenic
so arsenic is found naturally in our air
soil and water in large amounts it can
increase the risk heart disease cancer
respiratory illness and other health
problems alright so this story actually
did scare me because before I became a
huge YouTube star and now drink the
eight dollar bottle yes your wine I
drank a tremendous amount of two buck
chuck I mean a lot too much for an adult
yeah my [ __ ] knowledge two buck chuck two
buck chuck I mean so there arsenic you
shouldn't be drinking arsenic should you
uh technically no i did not be drinking
arsenic but i find it so refreshing yeah
cleanse the palate yes literally out of
your head yes your tongue falls out
totally [ __ ] [ __ ] is maybe not surprises
like if you drink wine can cost two
dollars and actually now I read
something somewhere that said that
trader joes to a chuck technically by
the technical definition of what wine is
it doesn't even technically quality wine
punch it's a bottle they're doing
something right and there will assault
bullets the grapes that are actually not
they get the worst grapes that are
thrown away from everything else inside
I love trader joe so I don't wanna
battle to make us all that they're
awesome buddy but here's the bigger
his story guess what people cheap wine
is going to kill you anyway alright for
other reasons you mean is gonna ruin
your liver you mean the arsenic part
it's going to ruin your liver line in
general or cheap one cheap wine because
guess what if you're drinking cheap wine
you probably drink a lot of it yeah and
it's you know people been drinking
ripple for a long time and been dying of
you know yes cirrhosis of the liver so
are you seeing a story like this how do
you then even go all right I'm not gonna
drink the two buck chuck right I'm not
going to do that but is the six dollar I
mean this is what everyone says with
mines all the time like there's a $58
bottle at a restaurant is that it gonna
be any better for you if that's the next
step it's going to be like ranked by
health or through a Brita filter I mean
that's what I do you buy that your ass
stuff you can find whether it's Bach
whatever is bored through a Brita filter
maybe they can sponsor the show I'm not
sure that science on people just for the
record there to do that yeah yeah if
you're drinking one or two glasses of
wine tonight I think you're going to be
okay it's all about moderation you
shouldn't be drinking a lot of alcohol
anyway it's not good for you people
clearly clearly someone who's also not
going to get their dog stoned I have to
disagree with also is I just wait they
have everything being equal most of the
drinking that I've done in la since I've
moved like ice is at your house so I'm
not exactly that just happened where you
mean but your butt your butt your
drinking decent wine there again I do
that's all it is I mean she gets a lot
of Kelly you know wonderful person as
these incredible we talked about it
before when were on incredible community
type I would call them garden parties
called the up the poly parties and
people always bringing gifts they bring
like nice wine every like Brent Francis
Ford Coppola none of this two-buck
Chuck's yeah yeah baby okay remember do
you remember that just recently as last
year they did a blind taste test they
had box wine hands like a thirty dollar
bottle yeah people could not pick the
different yes yeah so it's not about the
taste and to take the arsenic I think I
rather take the arsenic out of the wine
it's it's like it's like a contractor
doesn't spend the extra twenty cents of
foot to put copper the better grade of
copper in your walls that week you know
ten years later it wouldn't cost them
that much right so do we recommend this
one of these things I'm not pro relation
but we need
like the FDA or somebody like right you
know to me like right like they look at
every fruit juice that everyone drinks
they are like water corn high fructose
corn syrup and our water certainly so do
we need them to jump in here and start
dealing with the wine people smacks of
wine people around i sent you all the
way I be able to be Spencer I think part
of the roadside sterilization of white
people should be a nice class of two
buck chuck for sure if you want to know
about the roadside sterilization of
white people that was in our white
people segment we did earlier that's
something right over here and it's down
below also anyway two buck chuck is it
killing you let us know in the comments
right down below all right i want to
thank Kelly and Chad and I'm gonna let
you guys pimp yourself out pimple a
sister well people can follow me at
twitter i'm kelly underscore carlin like
chad i'm an underscore person and if you
want to you can pre-order my book online
it's called a Carlin Home Companion
it'll be out in five months six months
but which the pre order button they like
and it really exists because I saw copy
already it's a real physical storia oh
it's a story of my life and part of it
is growing up with my dad George Carlin
and my mother Brenda and all the crazy
[ __ ] I did in my life yeah dad what kind
of crazy shifty do you do in your life I
basically just follow kelly around and
listen to her crazy [ __ ] way or anything
in my credit um you know I basically
work as a director and a riot or so you
know I could tell you to follow the
commercials I've shot but you're
skipping them anyways so why would I do
that is much better follow me on twitter
if you'd like if you know you have
really nothing else to do and you you
want to take pity on me it's chad
underscore einbinder I'm not gonna spell
it for you cuz that's just embarrassing
yeah and you know just try to increase
the peace everything yeah man try to
increase the peace I'm of course at
Rubin report on Twitter thanks for
watching and we'll do it again next week